always excited to actually catch up with
the guy whose seat i'm sitting in for
the last couple days
rich eisen the host of the rich eisen
show is joining the rich eisen show with
kirk morrison
and for rich eisen thanks richard
um like what do you do now rich i mean
it's been
uh i limp on the plane and i come home
and i go on the air tomorrow right in
that chair and have daniel jeremiah
join and are you rich i know you gutted
it out
outstanding performance as always but
hey sometimes you got to play hurt and i
know you went out there and gutted it
out but
how sore are you um
scale of one to ten yes i'm
i don't know i'm i'm in the eight to
nine range right now
um brockman and then the story tomorrow
okay but um it it it reared its ugly
head
a little faster than i'd hoped yeah you
could see yourself uh
kind of grimacing on when they show the
package on nfl network just now
you know uh but it it was it's amazing
how
how physically demanding and every
people who like ran it
right um people who ran it just
for you know what's in giggles how
physically demanding
show that have been very generous to
chime in on nfl.com run rich run the
donate button is still there for people
to go to
we got an incredibly generous donation
from
a member of the nfl um who i'm still
trying to get clearance on
to announce because you know i i don't
people
make a donation i don't know if they
want it talked about or anything like
that but incredible
um that gives us an outside shot of
raising half a million bucks this year
alone
so it's pretty amazing amazing great job
awesome man
rich i'm i'm listening to the broadcast
and
outstanding job by you and daniel
jeremiah and
and then it's like bill belichick has
just come in and crashed the party and
and delivers a check to you for saint
jude's and i think people
we look at bill belichick the coach but
then when he comes in as bill bella
checked the person and kind of hand you
a check
just talk about that encounter yeah i
mean um
it it was crazy you know i was given a
little heads up that he might be coming
by
but i didn't know when and certainly not
during the middle of the linebacker
drills
and um you know he drops off the check
and shakes your hand gives you a thumbs
up and the fact that he does that and
you know obviously in the twitterverse
people will always be a hater or what
have you
but the fact that he does it on the air
means so much because it it
it raises awareness which is half the
battle of fundraising
is getting it out there awareness is
just such a crucial aspect of it
and the fact that he did do that the man
who's
with six lombardi trophies and as the
reigning
super bowl head coach uh for him to do
that just it just raises awareness
through the roof
you could see the the video getting
clipped off and shared and
stories written about it and each one of
those lends
to the fact that we had a record-setting
amount of donations just to our online
uh nfl.com run rich run site that set a
record this year
and i just think that there's just a lot
of people in this world that are looking
for
stuff to feel good about um and what's
what can make you feel better than
getting sick kids better
and belichick did it matt patricia did
it
mooch sent out a challenge to people to
do it and like i said a member of the
nfl community
uh made a record-setting donation
um and it's just pretty cool it's pretty
neat att
and the nfl nfl network and
marriott and wrangler and under armour
gave me the shoes they're all been
corporate partners and
sweat taylor i'll talk about it tomorrow
the suit that they made for me
it's if i only had run faster you know
i'm trying to i'm trying to
not fixate on the fact that i didn't set
a personal best but
there's next year when i'm 50. uh we're
joined now by rich eisen he is the host
of the rich eisens show i'm kirk
morrison filling in for rich and thanks
for doing this kirk
with these guys i always have fun and
like they're like my brothers you know
what i mean i get a chance to come out
on a
you know a little family vacation we
hang out until you get a chance to come
back but
you know rich i think for a lot of
people for me you are a familiar voice
when it comes to combine coverage but
this time it was a new partner you
mentioned daniel jeremiah's name
so with you and mike maya do you guys
try to avoid each other now when you're
at the combine
are you trying to get all the
information i ran into him in the
building
uh walking into the building the other
day on i forget what day was saturday
yes
and uh he just he's on sky he's on cloud
nine i mean this is
this is uh this is what he's this is
what he's been born to do is evaluate
and
and obviously doing this for television
is one thing but the fact that he's
doing it for real
right um is a is well for real obviously
he's doing it for real for the nfl
network but
as a professional tele evaluator not for
television before a team to
actually evaluate to win a real super
bowl
um is something that i think has really
humbled him
in a way that um that he's just he's
just you're scraping him off the ceiling
every day when he goes to work and
gruden's an interesting cat and he's got
three first-round picks
in his first timeout i mean not many
general managers have that ever in their
career let alone
first draft and um then he's going to go
to all these pro days but not on behalf
of path to the draft on the nfl network
but on behalf of the raiders
um he's loving it and he stopped by he
crashed the set during the 40-yard
dashes yesterday it was just like
riding a bike you know um so it was
something that he
he i think he enjoyed doing for two
segments it was great to have him back
and it just
speaks to dj's daniel jeremiah's
character and
um the fact that he has no ego or
uh that he's not like hey this is my gig
now and mayok's coming back it's just
everybody genuinely likes each other we
have a good time and hopefully that
comes through on the screen
well still the biggest takeaway from the
entire draft experience for you is
it's always you come in with the story
line right rich and then yeah
where does that storyline materialize
and when you walk away is it still the
big story line
for you what is that story line is it
still kyla murray as you walk into the
airport
it's got to be you know and i'll hit on
this a little bit more tomorrow probably
in the open of the show but
um you know we're leaving here with
pretty much
90 to 95 of the combine thinking he's
number one overall
which coming in is kind of crazy you
know and brockman you and i and we were
on the air on the radio and his
when his measurements came in the other
day and he was five ten and an eighth
and
you know back in the day uh somebody
measures five ten and eight
uh you you check the the the send home
box
you'd be like that's the end of that now
somebody checked the 5 10
8 box and it's like okay you're he's
ready so the
evaluation has totally changed for the
quarterback and i know that's what you
were talking about last week chris about
you know that that why do we have to
measure this stuff and you know what's
the difference between five
nine and three quarters and five ten and
one-eighth you know
the answer is half an inch but the
evaluation
has changed i mean there's no doubt that
people are evaluating a quarterback of
that size
uh totally differently
and whether whether he's number one
overall or not i don't know
um but we're leaving here thinking that
that's the case which means
an incredibly talented defensive line
group would get pushed further down if
that happens
which means you know the 49ers would get
most likely bosa the jets would have a
choice between quinn and williams and
other talented defensive linemen
and uh you know we might have the first
five picks the draft be
defensive lineman uh if they don't even
take kylo murray but somebody's going to
take him i think in the top five or
trade up
um and if it does go lineman lineman
for the start of the draft i think that
that would be the jets dream
that there they are in the three spot
with kyler murray
um i i think the phone would ring off
the hook
if that happens for them well let me ask
you that rich because that's our poll
question today where should
kylo murray be drafted you said 90 95 of
the combine thinks he's going number one
do you think he should go number one or
top ten first round
day two or later well i don't know how
about this
i will is what what are the results
right now
uh right now first round is uh leading
the way at 38
top 10 35 yeah i i think he's the
top ten pick for sure i think there's no
question about it there's no doubt about
it i i would be stunned if he even fell
out of the top ten
you know his the question when we were
talking about him
deciding between football and baseball
when we were you know when we hung up
the phone with him
day before hala heisman when he was on
our show
the the the question was well baseball
or football he's got to figure out what
what his draft status is and you know if
he's the 32nd overall pick in the draft
he would make just only a handful of
dollars less than what he's making his
baseball and
that that that that question is that
debate is over i mean that's
that's an antiquated conversation i mean
he is a top 10 pick as the day is long
and he's going to be a top five pick i
mean there's a tons of people who fell
in love with this kid
um unless you know something happens
totally unforeseen
um i think he's definitely a top 10.
rich eisen of the
rich eisen show joining the program kirk
morrison filling in for rich until uh so
before i ask you the next question are
you probable
doubtful for tomorrow we just want to
make sure other oh no i'm in for
tomorrow i mean i could still drag my
ass out of the house and get down to the
studio
for three hours okay so you are
probably on this flight this flight home
i'm gonna have you know hopefully
i need to get that aisle seat to get up
and stretch uh move around
you know i mean i think that's what i'll
be hydrating throughout the day
throughout the night i'll be
i'll be doing all that stuff i'll be
there tomorrow no i mean
and you've done uh you've done you've
done all you can do there kirk
so i'm i'll be back i appreciate it so
now should i move shaq out of the way
from the icy hot commercials and
enter rich eisen
yeah pretty much i'll take that over hey
rick
rich a couple more before we let you go
i i know that look it's been about colin
murray and dwayne haskins but
what other player or players really
caught your attention
over the last couple days well i mean
daniel jeremiah
again he's our first guest tomorrow um
uh he had the perfect he had the perfect
words for
dk metcalf he's the human bat suit yeah
he described him i mean that is just
insane on what he looked like and what
he ran and
you know the number of times he gets
there he's a top 10 pick and then bose
is a top 10 pick and quinn williams is a
top 10 pick
and so on and so forth we can keep going
down the list
um at some point somebody's going to
fall out of the tent top ten
and uh man people sitting there in the
middle of the first round are gonna be
very happy
um you know and the patriots uh chris if
they don't get
josh rosen with this whole thing as
you're hoping for you know i asked dj
uh during the broadcast how many uh
defensive players do you think he's
going to go in the first round and his
answer was
you could tell everybody that they can
only draft defensive players in the
first round no offensive players allowed
to be drafted in the first round
and the patriots would be very happy
with the player they get at number 32.
that's how deep wow on the defensive
side of the ball for this draft
so you know um at the top of the list is
nick bosa who i heard
players and teams were halfway through
the season saying well we have no chance
to make playoffs this year but at least
we have a shot at nick bosa
but that kid that showed up here and he
was he looked healthy
and um and uh dj called
quadzilla you know with his legs
so um it was pretty it was pretty
amazing seeing these defensive players
in the flesh
and um and they're coming they're coming
to the nfl this fall
you know last question before we let you
go rich how do you handle
misinformation versus truth when it
comes to
a lot of the evaluators there outside of
you know your your group of guys but
you have a general manager come on we
like this guy we like this guy you hear
what's going on in arizona now that
they're all in like you mentioned
on you know kyler murray possibly but
how do you handle the misinformation
versus trump i don't know i mean there's
a ton of people that just keep talking
and then sending stuff out um you know
the number of times that dj
held his phone up to me and showed me a
rumor that he had texted to him
uh it happened once an hour you know and
we'll see which ones pan in and pan out
but
you know thankfully we're i'm just in
the business of
certainly here just setting up somebody
like dj or charles or
or dion or whatever dm was on fire today
um
you know um that you know we're just
dealing with what we see on the field
and what we think of the kids and where
they think they should be
placed and wound up and leave their
conjecture to others
well rich i always want to thank you for
allowing me to uh sit at the at the desk
while you're away so i appreciate it man
safe travels
i know the guys can't wait for you to
come back and uh so can i man
is that true yeah i think one hundred
percent of course
oh my gosh
information or is that truth like you
tell me you do tell me
i mean that's the same thing he said you
know what go run another 40 in your suit
thank you that's my opinion great drop
mikey great job
all right we'll see you tomorrow
take care the rich eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern
on audience